laurence fautrat bonjour merci d'avoir
accepté notre invitation dans la
matinale de rtl france alors pour
commencer quel a été votre réaction
après ses propos sur la culture du viol
dans la police de la part de marine
chaste ont écouté ses on a été choqués
et on trouve évidemment que ces propos
sont inadmissibles
comment peut-on dire encore ces choses
là en étant élu de la république c'est
voilà on travaille au quotidien auprès
des forces de défense de police aussi
bien les gendarmes les pompiers la
police nationale la police municipale
c'est des gens qui s'engagent pour faire
respecter la loi
faire faire en sorte que notre
tranquillité publique soit soit bien
conservé et une élue de la république
appartenant au groupe des verts se
permet de tenir des propos d'une
violence d'une violence extrême rond on
ne comprend pas comment voulez vous
qu'on soit après crédible auprès de
cette jeunesse si les élus français est
arrêté et la république dise des choses
de dans ce style là c'est ici
inimaginable je me serais jamais permis
jamais jamais jamais permis elle a
présenté ses excuses en elle a reconnu
son erreur
ce tweet faisait suite à une pancarte
pendant la manifestation pour le droit
des femmes
ce week end à lyon où il y avait écrit
police égale scandale un sel voulait
mettre en lumière les le fait que les
policiers ont du mal encore à prendre
les témoignages des personnes victimes
de viol écoutez je sais pas ce qu'elle
voulait faire et ça lui appartient
en attendant ce qu'elle a dit est ce
qu'elle a fait n'est pas adapté au
travail et à la reconnaissance que nous
exprimons nous tous élus à ce corps à ce
corps d'état voilà donc après déjà
plusieurs dérapages qui se passe dans
notre ville de lyon sur différents
sujets je pense que quelqu'un
responsable c'est le maire de lyon et à
ce titre là elle devrait porter sa
démission tout simplement peut pas ne
pas porter ce genre de propos je crois
que le préfet le sous-préfet se sont
exprimés sur ce sujet aussi tout le
monde a été violemment choqué de notre
côté
vous savez je suis une femme et je
défend les droits des femmes va au
quotidien as uniquement lors d'une
manifestation et jamais ça ne serait
venu à l'idée de faire une pancarte de
dans ce style c'est voilà c'est c'la on
voit les accointances les accointances
de deux des élus verts avec des
pancartes de l'ultra gauche
révolutionnaire et et qui ne respecte
qui ne respectent rien malheureusement
une police effectivement eu malmené par
une partie de la population leur convoi
et notamment à lyon la france fait face
à une flambée de violences ces derniers
jours
oui alors il ya un fond janvier de
violence dans notre quotidien qui était
déjà compliquée à contenir puisque le
respect des lois et on se retrouve
souvent avec des zones de non droit de
non droit dans nos dans nos quartiers
dans nos villes mais une reste à un
non-respect des des institutions et j'ai
on voit on voit sur l'agglomération
lyonnaise de nombreux maires qui se font
agresser insulter menacer des menaces de
mort et c'est quasiment devenu une
banalité et leur quotidien vous voyez
pour porter ce genre de d'engagement il
faut être solide et il faut faire pâques
au delà des clivages qui peuvent être
politique
donc c'est un gros dérapage de la part
de cette de cet élu ça c'est clair
donc vous ça sert voilà quand on est élu
il faut avoir une sorte de devoir de
réserve pour soutenir les forces de
police qui sont
actuellement en première ligne
évidemment vous l'avez dit contre ces
violences dans certains quartiers à lyon
tout à fait ils sont vous savez ça fait
quand même pas mal de temps que c'est
dur il ya eu la crise des gilet jaune
maintenant on a des tensions urbaines
voilà ils font leur métier alors
peut-être qu'il est comme c'est comme
partout il ya il ya eu des incidents est
jeune mais on n'est pas non plus dans un
monde parfait à la mêlée en ordre et
donc ils n'ont pas prouvé leur
dévouement à la cause quoi c'est clair
en quelques mots comment est ce que les
policiers les gendarmes autour de vous
ont réagi après cette polémique vous
avez parlé moi j'en ai parlé j'aurais
parlé avec mes responsables de la police
municipale et effectivement ils se
disent on marche sur la tête comment une
élue comment une élue de n'importe quel
bord que se permettre de dire ça de ne
nous apparentés tous à des voleurs à des
violeurs excusez-moi potentiel est de
dire que c'est dans une culture etc et
que ce genre de faits nous les
pratiquons au quotidien il comprend pas
et c'est normal c'est un père de famille
il a engagés à nos côtés 24 heures sur
c'est inadmissible et incompréhensible
il n'y a pas de n'y a pas de moore
d'ailleurs à la base de 10 à 7 une élue
une collègue maire à la mère de
saint-genis-laval qui acquit à qui a
retweeté si vous préférez ce tweet et
qui s'est offusqué en disant mais mais
qu'est ce que c'est alors c'était
cocasse parce que l'élu vert en question
lui a dit mais on t'a pas vu lors de la
manifestation n'a pas voilà
obligatoirement à manifester nous c'est
au quotidien qu'on agit qu'ont les
femmes et les droits des femmes
voilà je crois qu'elle est un peu novice
et qu'elle n'a pas peut-être pas tout et
les règles encore en main et je pense
que la responsabilité du maire de lyon
est engagé et il ferait bien soin de
demander sa démission soit d'avoir un
euro un gros cas d'âge
si beaucoup laurence fautrat de nous
avoir apporté votre témoignage ce matin
en direct sur rt france